みなさんLINEスタンプ、何使ってますか？
まぁすごいねぇ
今いろんな種類のLINEスタンプがあると思うんですけども
僕が最近使ってるのはこちら
ア  ン  ニ  ュ  イ  　  ワ  ン  ち  ゃ  ん
というスタンプでございます
「多感なワンちゃんのスタンプです。」
「微妙な感情を表したい時にどうぞ。」
灰☆
僕こういうスタンプすきなんですよぉ
どうですこのレパートリー
ﾅﾙﾎﾄﾞｫ　　ｲｲﾈｪ
ｱｧ?　　ﾔｧ
ｼﾞｬｱﾅ!　　ｱｱ
ﾝﾝ?　　ｲｪｧ
ｳｪｯ　　ｳｰﾝ
ﾝﾝｰ　　ｳｰﾝ
ｱｧ　　ｵｫｫww
ﾝﾝ　　ﾝｰ
ｱｯ　　ｱｧｧ
ｳﾝ　　ｳｳ
ｳｪw　　ﾝ
ｱ　　ｳｰ
ﾝﾝ!　　ｳｪｪ
ｳﾝ　　ｳｰﾝ
ｳｳｯ　　ﾊｧ
ｱｯﾊw　　ｳｳｯ
ｳﾞｩ　　ﾌｯ
ﾝﾝ　　ﾝｯ
ﾌｯﾌ　　ﾝｰw
ﾌｧｱ　　ｳﾝw
ﾜｶﾘﾂﾞﾗｧｲ!!
だがそれが良いんです
そうこのスタンプ何かと言いますとぉ
全　く　意　味　が　分　か　ら　な　い
いろんな人に使ってきたんですけども
皆さんやっぱちょっと
ｲﾗｯとしてますね☆
まぁこの絶妙なスタンプを僕使ってるんですけども
それをですねぇ
Twitterでその使っててつぶやいたらぁ
とあるアカウントができていました。
はいこちら
謎　の　犬
IDが
@nazodog
説明文には
「わんわん」と書いてありますぅ…
フォロワーが一人
僕ですねぇ
でなんやかんや450人もフォロワーがいます
このアカウント
今回僕が正体を暴いていこうと思います
これなん…　全くわかんないんっすよ
何でできたんだろ…
そうだ最初僕がふざけて
なんか「わんわん」謎の犬からきたんで
「おぉ（適当）」と思って
返信したんだったかなぁ？
あぁそうだ
最初僕に「わんわん」って打ってきたんで
僕が…
笑った返信を送り返すと
「わんわん（通知めっちゃきて怖かった）」と
怯えているご様子です
謎　の　犬
まぁそこからこう定期的に
僕に文章送るようになったんですけど
基本的に全部「わんわん」しか言いません
たまに自分で訳を入れて
僕に文章を送りつけてくるという感じですね
「わおーん」とか
まぁこういう感じで
基本的には「わんわん」と「わおーん」しか
言えないタイプなんですけども
こう「わんわん」と「わんわん」…
めちゃくちゃ送ってくるんすよ（迫真）
ﾎﾝﾄに
ほとんどのつぶやきに「わんわん」って
送り返してくるんですけども
「お手」をすると「へっへっへっ」
で最近になると「ばうばう」と言いながら
こう画像も載せてくるようになってね
表情を表すようにもなってきました
これ誰がやってるのかなって僕思いましてー
ぃゃ怪しいじゃないですか
普通に
ふつーに怪しいです
僕がこの犬のスタンプを愛しすぎて
ひょっとしたらその具現化してしまって
この謎の犬のスタンプ自体に魂がこう憑依してしまって
ひょっとしたらスタンプの犬が…
こう魂…
ｲﾔｿﾚﾊﾅｲﾜ
（すいませんそれは）ないです
今回ね謎の犬の中身の人をちょっとね
確かめていきたいと…思いますっ
では早速謎の犬と喋っていきましょう
まずは先制パンチだな
まずは先制パンチで「わんわん」と送っておきましょう
まぁこのあとの出方しだいだなぁ
待ち時間暇なんだよなぁ…（困惑）
この時間に謎の犬が
Twitterをやってるかやってないかっていうのも
ポイントですから
まぁあとは出方ですね
どこまでそのわんわんキャラを貫くか
はたまたDMになるとバンバン喋り出すか
※ダイレクトメッセージ(DM)とは送信ユーザーと受信ユーザーにしか見れない非公開メッセージ。ツイートを「d 送信先ユーザー名　メッセージ内容」という形式で作成すると、ダイレクトメッセージとして送信される。DM（ディーエム）と省略して呼ぶこともある。　　　　　　　　　　　 　ツイナビより
ﾅｿﾞﾉｲﾇｩｩｩｩ!!
野菜ジュース「ファッ！？」
あれから謎の犬からの返事はなかったんですけども
ふと見たら
返事が返ってきておりました
「わんわん　今働いておりました」
「すみません」
「わんわん」
働 い て る ん で す ね 。
働いてるということが分かったので
謎の犬は
きっと社会人の説があります
で、さっきすぐ「こんばんわ」って送ったら
「こんばんわん」
「！！」
ちょっとびっくりしてる様子です
ああぁ　あの
髪の毛切りました
こっからちょっといろいろ話してみましょうか
はいというわけで「今何してますか？」と言ったら
「youtube見てました」と
なかなか…いい趣味の犬ですな
「関心です。」
「ありがとうございます」
「　わ　ん　」
まだちょっと本人の中身に踏み込むのは早いので
もうちょっとちょっと質問してみます
まぁ食べ物で大体その人のイメージというか
そういうのは分かるんで
なんだ　何を　何を…
何を好きなんだろ
ﾌﾞｯｗｗｗ
骨か…ｗｗｗ
まぁ犬らしいっちゃぁ犬らしいなぁ
「謎の犬ですから…」
やべぇ　コレ動画にしていいか聞いてなかったから聞こう
あぁこれの反応によりますね
なんかこう動画にしたいからひょっとしたら
謎の犬のアカウントを作ったっていう人も今いますから
これでちょっと「イヤです」とか言ったら本物だよ
間違いなく…
もう待ってましたみたいな
「全然大丈夫ですよ！」
ここ一番で喜んでるからねもう
さぁそろそろプライベートな質問に迫っていきましょうか
結局私も皆さんもこの中身の人が誰か、
どんな人がやっているのか、知りたいと思うので
ここら辺をちょっと攻めていきましょうか
泣いてらっしゃる（無慈悲）
「さてさて、」
「あなたの正体を暴きますよ…？」
「あなたぁ…　謎の犬ではないですね？」
お、返ってきてる
「そ……そんなわけないじゃないですか」
怪しいなぁ
ここはちょっと同士っぽく威嚇していきます
同じ犬ということが分かればまた
対応が変わってくるかもしんないからね
「ワオーン」
さぁこっからですねぇ
さぁちょ聞くよじゃあ
まずは年齢からいきましょう
「犬さんは何歳なのですか？！」
これで謎の犬さんの年齢が分かりますね
さぁなんて返すか
「人間的には18」…
あ、結構若いなぁ…
18で働いていたということは
バイトしてるかもう働き出しているかのどっちかです
オスかメスかは気になるところですね
オスか　ほぅほぅほぅ
そこはやっぱりちょっと…
アイコンと一緒ですね
18歳のオスですね
じゃあちょっとここでバシッと聞いてみましょう
まぁ始めたのには多分皆さん理由があると思うので
なぜこの謎の犬さんは
まぁ犬にしろ人間にしろ
どうしてＴｗｉｔｔｅｒを始めたかをちょっと聞いてみたいところはある
さぁどう来る…？
ｵｫ
「やることがなかったもんで……………」
「まさかこんなことになるとはww」
やる事がなかったみたいです。
ほぅほぅほぅ
ほぅほぅ
高校生みたいですね彼は
なるほどなるほど
まさか受験生じゃないだろうね
18歳ってことは受験生じゃないの？
「一応もう終わってます」
おぉぉぉぉ…　お疲れ様です
これはでもあれだね
なんかその偽アカウントとかじゃなくて
ホントにただ楽しんでるだけなんで
僕は全然こういうのは…いいと思います
「これからも、謎の犬として頑張ってくれ！」
「応援してるよ！」
じゃ「最後に視聴者さんに一言あれば…　ぜひ！」
来たぞありがたいお言葉です…！
「see you next time!!」
あ？（威圧）
セイキン「ファッ！？」
( 。∀ ﾟ)